this is serious scores of jihadi brides
including some from the UK's the biggest
female terror cell want to come back to
Britain
according to reports that's despite
Whitehall officials warning that these
women are as big a security threat as
jihad amen
it would be lunacy to allow these women
back their murdering husbands and even
some of them were involved in some of
the worst violence the kind of violence
that saw women and children being raped
and then buried alive men being beheaded
and burned in cages and even if some of
these women weren't directly involved
the act of marrying a terrorist means
they were complicit so now they
shouldn't be allowed back here
particularly when government sources say
it will be virtually impossible to
prosecute any of them these women can't
pretend that they didn't know what they
were getting into when they joined the
mass murdering cult the diseases and
even if they left as naive ish teenagers
they aren't anymore
they're radicalized and they're
dangerous which is why the British
people should not have to have them back
or pay a penny towards trying to turn
them into decent human beings because
that ship has sailed
so I have every sympathy for the way in
which you describe these women and I
think they are dangerous I think they
are beyond the pale they are extremists
would be too polite a word to describe
them they voluntarily went to join the
worst terrorist group in our living
memory and married people that are
serious criminals work they're still
alive the concerns I have Carol with
your recommended solution to the problem
are twofold one is I recoil every time I
hear anything that sounds to my ears
like we Britain as a country dumping our
toxic waste and they are toxic waste on
other countries and expecting them to be
able to deal with it what ends up
happening instead is they end up in
uncovered zones and areas like for
example parts of northern Nigeria or in
Somalia or Yemen or in Chechnya and
other areas where this conflict
Afghanistan and they end up becoming
potent and hardened and trained fighters
and causes problems down the line the
second concern
yeah that's that bringing the second
concerning is that legally and I often
think of these things legally because
the precedence they set the when you
start stripping nationalities and
stripping citizenship from people that
clearly nobody likes including me you
end up setting legal precedents and it
becomes bigger than the person that
you're stripping them from and you end
up those legal precedents end up getting
used in other cases in a form of mission
creep so when for example we had an
extradition treaty with the United
States of America that they didn't
ratify that we did it obliged us to send
over anybody alleged to have committed a
terrorist offense by the Americans even
without seeing evidence there very
likely everyone has said Whitehall the
Security Service has said there's no way
we're gonna be able to gather evidence
to prosecute any of them so what that
what happens is they come back here they
get to walk back into the lives they had
before and and Richard Barrett who was
who was there the head of mi6 for global
terrorism he said quietly people who
have been in Iraq and Syria are still
committed to violence yeah so so so mi5
now or monitoring 3,000 terrorists and
they're struggling with the resources we
have to do that so we're gonna give them
80 80 more are jus imminently that's
probably another 20 or 30 before
Christmas where would you do you know
the famous quick I don't care but you're
saying I don't care I don't care the
reason why you shouldn't write anything
exactly not your job I just don't know
what to do know if you're in government
it is your job and that's the problem
and we all understand what you're saying
but the problem is what do you do with
it where do they go this is always the
question people I'm not a politician up
but the the the people who are there to
decide that actually don't know what to
do them because what they're gonna do is
let them back in probably with their
kids I'm on some of whom have been
radicalized France that day with a
sensible thing they're letting the kids
in but not none of the parents which
makes sense to me because at least those
kids have a chance then to be D
radicalized remember we're not for
insane goodness and what I would say is
so you think it's a good thing to let me
let me finish I get your point
I totally get your point just as Majid
said before
it's unenforceable they are British
citizens so what are we going to do no
we have we have way to revoke their
citizen you actually have there's a way
to utilize them for the information
gathering that's what I'm saying is if
we have no choice but to let the people
in the question the conversation we
should be having instead is what do we
do with them not even looking at that is
the conversation we should be having not
offer any solutions and someone because
we debated this and I wonder what the
the pledges make of this idea when we
talked about this on the radio station
the URL on majid somebody phoned in and
said there's a European country where
they are pursuing the idea that although
they might be citizens a British isms if
they are obstruction of Iraqi or
Pakistani or in my case Switzerland if
they can find out that your mum or your
dad or even your grandparents were born
then you're going to be shipped back
there if you are deemed to be if you are
deemed to be a terror suspect
so we renounce everything you have a
Pakistani or a Swiss grandfather or
whatever it might be an Iraqi father I'm
not saying I'm just saying it is an idea
there's no reason on earth why there but
why should we take them which is I agree
with Carol this so I tell you why we
should take because they so most of
these jihadi brides are converts or born
and raised here and raised here the
British and their radical ization happen
on our watch
not on Pakistan's watch not on whichever
country right and so those countries are
going to say to us well last thing I'll
say is obviously I've been following
this for many many years
and the last thing I'll say on this is
that if you try let's take Pakistan
right we try and send these guys back to
Pakistan say the 7/7 bomber right yeah
and we and it's imagine he didn't die
and which one is send him back to
Pakistan Pakistan can rightfully say to
us hold on we had years of the Afghan
war where we were the Soviets invading
Afghanistan and we had a whole bunch of
these foreign fighters that no state
wanted back especially Saudi Arabia look
what they did ended up doing they ended
up going to Iraq in Syria and creating
Isis but you must have a certain explain
to you or your chills
today's analyze them have been talking
here these women have been talked to in
Syrian already they're denying any
involvement and then he terrorist active
they're lying as of course they would
notice it before their British citizens
that the law here there is a law that
allows us to strip the citizenship of
someone whose quotes presence in this
country is not conducive to the public
good I would say the the presence of
these women in this country is not
conducive then why do they go there
stuck in Syria you know that's where
they've been living the cards even
prison by the curse you don't want them
but we don't have the resources and the
Kurds don't even have a state you know
poor Kurds are expected to defeat Isis
and then deal with the prisoners of Isis
after they've defeated said they are our
toxic waste we have to figure out what
to do with them well we should let them
to come back here because as we can't
prosecute it was real means they go back
terrorists was in this country and did
something and we try to deport them to
Saudi Arabia and Assad we said we
stripped him of his citizenship we don't
want in fact let's see what the Foreign
Office says cause it's quite an the
Foreign Office says the following the UK
advises against all travel to Syria as
all UK consular services are suspended
in Syria is extremely difficult to
confirm the whereabouts and status of
British nationals there anyone who does
travel to Syria for whatever reason is
putting themselves in considerable
danger and Greg you right I know only
floated the idea that came on the radio
show the trouble is we've discovered
that one of them is of Swiss origin to
use my dad I'm just gonna say no thank
you he's not going to Geneva they've got
enough problems amidst or they don't
need me when they get back here there
should be put in detention centers until
they can be what you should be looking
at then if we find out they're involved
then we stripped them of their
citizenship tell them to go wherever
then but we should not be paying for
terrorists for people who have done what
I described in my intro you're very
women and children alive you rape them
you behead people we shouldn't allow
them to come back here and live a normal
life alright it's time to draw a veil
over the subject of jihadi prides you're
watching the pledge on Sky News and it
me up next exit
[Music]